the Mendocino complex wildfire in
Northern California is now the largest
in state history think about that for a
second it's burned more than 443 square
miles an area nearly as large as a city
of Los Angeles the Mendocino complex is
one of 15 large fires burning in
California today John Blackstone is in
Ukiah without conditions for 14,000
firefighters on the front lines are
getting worse John good morning good
morning well this promises to be another
tough day for firefighters here with
temperatures expected to rise into the
90s now this massive fire camp is the
base for nearly 4,000 they were battling
the Mendocino complex fire with
California getting hotter and drier
experts say almost any fire can now turn
into a massive one it took the Mendocino
complex fire just ten days to make
history as California's largest fire
ever and it comes at a time when huge
wildfires are breaking out across the
state what's it been like here the last
couple of years we've been we've been
busy cAL FIRE spokesman willpower's is
on the frontlines the Mendocino complex
fire is actually two adjacent fires now
covering more than 440 square miles
that's an area more than a hundred
square miles bigger than New York City
full containment isn't expected until
next week it's really deep train in
there okay so we're not able to put
ground personnel in some of those areas
President Trump addressed the disaster
Monday tweeting the wildfires are made
so much worse by the bad environmental
laws which aren't allowing massive
amounts of readily available water to be
properly utilized but cAL FIRE tells CBS
News there are no water issues and the
true problem is climate change we do
have lots of water yes there's no
denying wildfires have taken a huge toll
on California this year destroying over
1,800 structures and burning more than
half a million acres at least nine
people have died as the urban sprawl
continues in California and we have
people moving into
Wildmutt areas it has been continuing
for the last 30 years for the people
living here the year-round fire season
means permanent lifestyle changes so you
just sleep with your fuse by your bed
this has been the scariest one the
problem of home construction in wooded
areas is only expected to get worse one
study says that by 2050 another 645
thousand houses will be built at areas
at very high risk for wildfires viana
and as that firefighter said it
containment is not expected until next
week Wow John thank you